so from reading your bio you have a
Great backstory which I just wanted to
check in with I know you if I said it
like 50 million times but it's really
fascinating so here goes I understand
you you say you were broke working as a
waiter mmm in New York yes in New York
and Ohio Oh dual waiter ship yeah well
it started in Ohio and then I moved to
New York okay God all right so waiting
tables and I know that's you can have a
great night and you can have a horrible
night
so someone commented one day when you
went in oh there goes Obama and it was
what another co-worker another co-worker
I came into work one Dame and this girl
goes up here comes Obama and everyone
started laughing and I laughed it was
only the she'll he said I was the only
black guy that worked there so but
everyone laughed and I laughed but then
I had an epiphany
and I was like you know what like I
could come up with an impression of this
guy hit at the time he was still running
for office he hadn't become president
yet and I just had an epiphany like what
if I get in to do an impression of this
guy before anyone else does it before
he's famous because if he becomes
president he'll be the most popular guy
on the planet and that would be a lot of
steam for my acting career so right and
this was what year that you were 2008
2008 so you'd already launched a YouTube
yeah I launched my youtube channel in
2005 five okay and how much time were
you putting into the channel 2005
because those were the easy days it
seems like a little bit a little easier
than easier yeah yeah um how much time I
was doing it a lot like basically all of
my free time I was working on my youtube
channel
oh okay so you come back were you tired
sometimes from these shifts and looks
like uh but then you like put in time
yeah because that was like my escape
that was like my dream so it's like am I
in my head doing these silly YouTube
videos back in 2008 seven six
that was an escape for me and in my head
I felt like I was a big director you
know I get to do these silly sketches
and and and you know skits and whatnot
and it was my escape at the time you
know and what were people's comments to
you about this this YouTube things most
people most people were supportive you
know most people liked it online you can
almost anyone can find an audience and
so online I had begun to find mine and
so people were watching and most people
were
supportive and you know about it right
so then you do this
Obama video and it seems like your life
pretty much changes from that point
right um do you remember the day that
you launched it and like what happened
were you at work when view started
coming in yeah I mean I had already
begun to get a lot of use of my own but
then the when I put up my first Obama
video after that girl made that comment
at work you know I came home and I took
a napkin that I had left over my apron
and I started just writing down ideas
and so I wrote down a whole script and
then I sat in from the camera and
performed it and I was really nervous
because I hadn't done impressions before
then and I thought people got I think it
was stupid and I put it up and then just
like tens of thousands of you started
coming in I was like oh they like this
hey you know so then in from there was
just I just started doing more and it
just took off
so did you promote it in any way or
because you know I was Twitter even
around them I don't even know I'm pretty
sure it was but I don't think I was it's
not like I had a following on Twitter or
Instagram I don't think Instagram was
around back then um it just did what it
did on its own I'd already built like a
network you know followers on on YouTube
so Wow so then how soon from that day
that you launched it did you actually
say did you give you two weeks or maybe
you didn't then you said no it's it no I
didn't give my two weeks right away um
but around that time YouTube had
launched a or a little bit before that
time YouTube had launched a an ad
revenue share program where content
creators could make money from posting
videos and I had gotten accepted into
that so I was slowly beginning to make a
little little side change you know not
much at all but then what happened
around the Ilan on the own Election Day
when he won I posted a parody of a TI
song and it just blew up and that was
the moment from there that I was
actually able to get out of a job
because of ad revenue share income and
also branded opportunities and outside
opportunities you know like hosting for
Entertainment Tonight and things like
that it just things that crazy really
fast do you remember the exact timeframe
a month two months that times my block
from the time that you actually made
that video that first video to where you
were out of that nine to five it was
about a month that I would then I went
from broke and unemployed at the time
because I wasn't even waiting tables by
that point I gotten fired from my last
waiting job and moved out here from New
York to here and so came here was
unemployed was unemployment I started
making videos and I was just I promised
myself I wasn't going to go back to
waiting tables again and I had just
taken an interview at a restaurant and
had gotten hired and was about to take
the job and then that video blew up and
all this money suddenly came rushing in
and then I never went back to waiting
tables after that when you were fired
was it a blessing or was it it was a
blessing because it needed to happen and
it just you know it freed me up to do
other things you know so yeah it sounds
like perfect timing
you